an scp foundation researcher sits at a
table inside of a standard containment
cell
these are often dangerous places to be
especially when the scp you're supposed
to be studying
is one that you can't see the researcher
is taking notes
unsure of exactly what is going to
happen next
he can hear the sounds of knives
scraping behind
of flesh sizzling and searing from high
heat
he braces himself as a burst of heat
hits the back of his head
as if a fireball has erupted an object
floats through the air and settles in
front of him on the table
it's a plate of food and it looks
delicious
it may surprise you to learn that there
is no rule that the scp foundation must
deal exclusively
with violent and vicious creatures not
every scp
held in containment shares the same
malevolence and contempt for humanity as
scp-682 or the world-ending threat posed
by the likes of scp-23
some perhaps not many but some are
benign and might even seem
outwardly friendly but you'd still be
taking a huge risk to assume that
anything contained by the scp foundation
is completely harmless such is the case
with scp-5031
as per the foundation's containment
procedures this quasi-humanoid
meaning it appears to have some vaguely
human features
is held in an airtight cell that is
regularly checked by foundation
personnel on a bi-weekly basis
scp-5031 has no need for regular
nutrition
or regular interactions from staff the
trick with scp-5031
is not being eaten by it since though it
doesn't need
food it does still hunt and consume
anything it encounters
human or otherwise avoiding being eaten
is hard enough with creatures that can
actually be
seen but like so many other creatures
the foundation keeps contained
scp-5031 has developed an almost perfect
defense mechanism
which is when observed it will literally
cease
to exist some might choose to refer to
this as a quantum lock
however it is worth noting that traces
left by scp-5031
still remain observable when the
creature has temporarily disappeared
for example trails of blood and scratch
marks left behind by scp-5031
still exist when the scp itself does not
naturally this makes both avoiding the
creature and capturing it using cameras
difficult
however when scp-5031's existence ceases
it still
casts a shadow from this researchers
have been able to determine several of
the creatures physical traits
based on its silhouette it has been
deduced that scp-5031 levitates about
half a meter above ground level
sports an abnormally small necklace head
atop an elongated torso
approximately 1.9 meters long with three
sets of spindly lower arms that branch
outwards
using these arms and its loosely hanging
body scp-5031 will lower itself to hunt
any human or animal that draws near to
it
and uses the blade-like tail to cut up
food
perhaps the most interesting facet of
scp-5031 beyond its defensive
capabilities and apparent physical
attributes are the series of nine tests
conducted by senior researcher stanley
huxtable
appalled by the conditions that the
creature was being kept in
huxtable took over the role of hcl
supervisor for scp scp-5031
having grown increasingly frustrated and
empathetic towards the creature
listening to its screams from inside its
iron containment unit huxtable devised a
series of tests to introduce
scp-5031 to various different stimuli
as a way to better understand the
creature and hopefully keep it contained
in a way that didn't seem to cause so
much suffering
it's worth remembering that the scp
foundation makes its mission to be cold
not cruel in performing their duties to
protect normality
and many of the researchers and staff
are just as capable of having empathy
for creatures
as you might for a stray animal at a
shelter
the first of huxtables tests involved
installing speakers in scp-5031
cell through which a variety of
different ambient and popular pieces of
music were played to see if they had any
effect on reducing the creature's stress
by judging scp-5031 stress levels based
on how much it screened when compared to
normal
huxtable was able to determine how to
best use music to calm the creature
scp-5031 seemed to convey higher levels
of stress when listening to morning
forest
deep grotto and seaside paradise
ambience
as well as the best of late 60s british
rock band jethro tull
however the best of mozart enya kiss and
ben folds produced dramatically
different results
decreasing scp-5031's apparent stress
following this test senior researcher
huxtable compiled a playlist featuring
scp-5031's favorite music
over time the stress-reducing effects of
music on scp-5031 seemed to decrease
but keeping the playlist on shuffles
seemed to keep the creature consistently
calmer than it had been
previously the next test involved
introducing inanimate objects into
scp-5031's enclosure to monitor its
reactions
and how its stress levels were affected
when a softball was thrown into the
enclosure
scp-5031 immediately sliced the ball in
two
with its tail in one swift motion a
similar result occurred when researchers
threw the creature of basketball
which was quickly punctured and sliced
open by scp-5031's tail
its stress levels first seemed to
diminish when the creature was offered a
bowling ball
which it rolled around the enclosure and
then later knocked it against a second
bowling ball
however when one of the balls chipped
rendering it unable to roll properly
scp-5031 stress increased dramatically
until a replacement was offered
researcher huxtable noted that scp-5031
seemed to possess a similar level of
motor skills to an
average human toddler with similarly
explosive emotional reactions to match
next when given the choice between two
food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure
scp-5031 seemed to gravitate towards
higher quality food
most notably favored cooked rotisserie
chickens over animal carcasses
it even chose this option over a live
chicken using its tail to cut its food
into more manageable bite-sized portions
rather than ripping its meat with its
hands or teeth like many of its fellow
scps researcher huxtable recorded these
findings and highlighted that
even though scp-5031 didn't need to eat
in order to survive
providing the creature with food of a
better quality marginally reduced its
stress
senior researcher huxtable next
attempted to test scp-5031's coexistence
with other living subjects
each time making sure that the creature
had been adequately fed to avoid any
unseemly incidents first a live chicken
was introduced
scp-5031 rolled its bowling ball at high
speed towards the chicken
increasing both its and the chicken
stress levels and inadvertently killing
the chicken in the process
when a second chicken was introduced
scp-5031 gently rolled a basketball
towards it but ceased any further
engagement after the chicken squawked
from being hit by the ball
next to be introduced into the enclosure
was a blindfolded d-class staff member
who was instructed to sit down and roll
the basketball towards scp-5031
after doing so for several minutes the
creature began to approach the d-class
subject
who was instructed to remove their
blindfold to cease the creature's
existence
and prevent any potentially deadly
incidents finally
researcher huxtable had another class d
engage in a game of catch with scp-5031
while facing away from the creature
this test proceeded successfully and
senior researcher huxtable remarked how
scp-5031's motor skills were improving
albeit gradually and with some gentle
encouragement
through huxtable's tests the creature
was learning
the next test focused on teaching
scp-5031 linguistic symbols
utilized lcd displays and buttons
connected to a food dispenser
one display showed an image of a rock
and the other an image of a rotisserie
chicken
after some brief probing scp-5031 was
quickly able to understand that pressing
the button
under the correct display would dispense
a rotisserie chicken for it to eat
the creature was later able to adapt
when the following day
the screen displays and materials
dispensed were swapped
and then later set to swap at random
intervals when additional rock
dispensing stations were introduced
this time displaying the word rock as
opposed to an image
scp-5031 was able to determine which
station dispensed
chicken through a process of elimination
whenever the functions and displays were
swapped
scp-5031 would find whichever displayed
the word chicken to receive its food
the final phase of this test presented
scp-5031 with a single station
displaying the word chicken but with a
button that would remain inactive unless
the creature spelled out the same word
with a collection of lettered blocks it
was provided with
after some initial confusion and
frustrations as to why the button would
not dispense food when pressed
scp-5031 was able to assemble the word
correctly
not only activating the button and
dispensing food
but proving to researcher huxtable that
the creature was capable
of learning language huxtable continued
to test the creature
encouraging it to spell words using
lettered blocks as a method of
communicating
by increasing scp-5031's vocabulary and
the amount of human interaction it
received
senior researcher huxtable observed that
scp-5031 was gradually learning to sing
albeit non-verbally as well as to juggle
with its six hands and was even
communicating its food preferences
and dish pairings later another class d
d52125 was introduced to scp-5031's
enclosure to aid in further testing
through d52125's instructions the
creature quickly learned to draw using
crayons
and created artworks depicting itself
its newfound friend d52125
researcher huxtable a cat and a
rotisserie chicken
scp-5031's new creative side didn't stop
there though
as the creature quickly learned to play
chopsticks in only two days once a piano
was introduced into
the enclosure scp-5031 even managed to
start creating its own original
admittedly crude compositions next a
spice rack was placed inside the
creature's cell
and d-52125 demonstrated how to season
mead
this proved to be scp-5031's new
favorite hobby
as it spent the next three days
experimenting with different
combinations of foods and spices
using its letter blocks to request more
more more
garlic powder interestingly the creature
only created artwork or music when
d52125 was present
but seemed to thoroughly enjoy its
experimentation with food when left
alone
following this development senior
researcher huxtable devised a new test
for scp-5031
providing the creature with cooking
utensils and using d52125 to demonstrate
5031 was shown how to prepare a variety
of different dishes
from hamburgers and tacos to mongolian
beef
steak clam chowder and profiteroles in
addition to a small peanut allergy
this eighth test revealed scp-5031 to be
a phenomenal chef
possessing culinary skills far beyond
the average person
the creature quickly and
enthusiastically embraced its newfound
talents
concocting its very own brand new
recipes with d52125 even volunteering to
be the first to taste test 5031's dishes
it was shortly after this test that
scp-5031
spoke its very first word and it should
come as no surprise
that the word was salt naturally senior
researcher huxtable was very
proud of the progress the creature had
made with its development
the final test almost seemed to be what
the creature was born for
over the course of two months scp-5031
was tasked with creating a full
three-course meal
which would then be served to foundation
staff for thanksgiving
scp-5031 not only rose to the task
but exceeded all of researcher
huxtable's expectations
creating a meal that even gordon ramsay
would be hard-pressed to find fault with
the creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup
seasoned with turmeric
next came a beautiful duck confit glazed
luxuriously with apple cider
and topped generously with sweet
cranberry compote paired with a side of
butternut squash gnocchi and served on a
bed of kale
seasoned with truffle salt the grand
finale of the exquisite meal was a
spiced cassava pie for dessert
complemented with the finest french
vanilla ice cream and a maple hazelnut
syrup
and scp-5031 didn't stop there the
creature also debuted one of its
original musical compositions to
complement the decadent meal it had
created
as the staff enjoyed the food scp-5031
performed live from its enclosure the
deeply moving
piano concerto for six hands to an
overwhelmingly positive response from
not only senior researcher huxtable
but the entire foundation staff as a
fitting end to the creature's tale
huxtable reported that during the
thanksgiving banquet it had created
scp-5031 stress levels reduced entirely
new kinder containment measures that
would keep 5031 safer but also
far more contented were submitted for
approval
perhaps some of you may find it
refreshing to learn that scp-5031 isn't
simply just another malicious malevolent
monster that the foundation has to keep
under lock and key for the safety of the
world
instead scp-53 is a gentle
if a little frightening at first
creature that just requires careful
and considered guidance instead of a
cold iron cage
and around-the-clock arm guards through
testing
senior researcher stanley huxtable and
his fellow foundation staff
were not only able to help the creature
develop but also found what makes it
tick
and not just for the purposes of
containing it instead
it is hoped that scp-5031's creativity
and flair for culinary and musical
masterpieces can continue to thrive and
grow
under the proud watch of researcher
huxtable
now for something from the more
terrifying archives of the scp
foundation
check out scp-096 the shy guy
or scp-106 the old man